[Musique]
le génie de la bastille ne contemple
plus qu'une gare vide la naissance du
rer a entraîné la désaffection de la
gare de la bastille les habitants de la
banlieue qui par centaines y arrivait
tous les matins descendent maintenant
dans d'autres stations ultramoderne
fermé depuis le mois de décembre la gare
silencieuse attend la décision des
autorités que deviendra-t-elle ans les
projets sont nombreux cela va du parking
à l'utilisation par une station de radio
périphérique des émissions publiques
pourrait en effet se dérouler sous la
voûte de verre en attendant les pendules
se sont arrêtés à l'heure du dernier
train il ne reste plus que quelques
employés chargés du déménagement des
archives
poussant plus loin notre petite enquête
nous avons remonté l'avenue daumesnil
jusqu'à la gare suivante c'est à dire
celle de paris ri
ici il règne une certaine activité des
wagons de marchandises y arrive encore
régulièrement mais les voies empruntées
par les trains de banlieue sont
désormais le territoire des moineaux
mais pendant des dizaines d'années des
gens ont vécu avec le train ceux qui
travaillent ou habitent sous les voies
nous avons voulu connaître leurs
réactions maintenant que leur vie n'est
plus troublés par le passage de ses
trains
monsieur est ce que le fait que les
trains ne passe plus à changer un petit
peu votre vie à ma place
on s'en rend compte moi-même j'en fait
au moins pour un temps de repos parce
que vous habitez juste au dessus c'est à
dire contre l'être davantage pour moi je
travaille dessus avec moi ce désert d un
peu est-ce que ce silence vous gêne pas
c'est à dire vous êtes habitués au bruit
est ce que si la jda se joue ça ne vous
gêne pas j'avoue désoriente pas plutôt
etc train qui passait le matin de bonne
heure est ce que ça vous serez pas un
petit peu de réveil matin
pas pour moi parce que je me lève le
célèbre homme d'affaires pour beaucoup
de clients même qu'il étaye les cinq
heures bal salle juste au moment où le
thrace passé monsieur est ce que ce
silence après le départ des trains ça a
changé quelque chose dans vos habitudes
voilà il y en a qui m'ont réveillé le
matin jacques heure et demie de temps en
temps on voit toujours alors ça me
réveillais et je voulais voir si cette
heure
tandis que maintenant je n'entends plus
vous ferez veille matin maintenant ils
font avec matin puis alors il y avait un
peu de charbon qu'il ya plus maintenant
il y avait déjà rigide et le charbon
tout en baies de l'omo mais parce que
c'était des locomotives à vapeur qui
passèrent harris et le comédien toujours
je vais toujours dit de mettre des
diesels on m'a dit non
les boutons pas assez solides pour
porter des diesels vous receviez
beaucoup de poussière de charbon il sera
encore assez au registre puis avec eric
et moi pour 30 tellement tellement
pourquoi je fais des matches enfin moi
le chemin de fer une gêne est pour
beaucoup
[Musique]